welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
and so here it is gene it's show time
the business is done let's get into it
with the real news you ready yeah
let's get this show started okay yeah
today I'm going to be your doctor so I
am dr. Mel you can call me dr. Mel and
today we are going to talk about ways to
tell her pussy's things oh it's my
auntie don't bring anyone
[Music]
I have AIDS minor right now why did you
turn away to blow your nose from the
microphone when you know the audience
likes to hear it
no it's just habit I'm a polite guy
you're not polite I am polite you know
look they loved it when I sneezed it
became a worldwide sensation I would
sneeze but I didn't know his knees you
brought home aids from nerd braska man
and I shoot a special this week it's the
worst possible time yeah yeah I went to
the doctor and I just said like look man
normally I just ride this out he's just
a cold or something but I can't risk
anything so he's just like we'll just
give you fucking high dosage everything
don't risk it he told me don't risk it
don't text while driving so we'll see
you man I hope I'll make it through it
you I I know you will and here's why
you're strong you've also got many days
to go in the week so you'll know
hopefully you'll be strong by the time
you have to tape and you know something
else you're a pro you've been doing this
for a million years you know you've done
it you've done stand-up sick now that
you want to it's terrible
but you know what you'll get an
adrenalin push you know what happens
like you can perform with a fever of
like 102 and diarrhea because your body
shuts it down
I booked a car to drive me for that show
tomorrow yeah I was like what a kit you
know I mean like this one relax in the
car yeah not be stressed about it don't
breast pussies are stinking people yeah
yeah what's going on I can tell you I
don't because but I don't and I'm
talking about what guys I've been taking
me they've been oh my god I fuck this
bitch got booty smell so bad
hey Melanie Wow dr. Mel dr. Mills oh my
fuck this bitch yeah jeez take her to a
clam clam make her twerk tell her hey
how about you twerk if she says no is
she say I can't talk cuz everybody clean
and then when she twerks that's a way
cuz you know she'd be moving the booty
and then the
opens up opens up opens up and then
dismay of this eye comes out so I think
she has a lot of experience actually
validating dr. Melanie well how would
you know how to identify a stinky B
unless you have one well I don't know I
wouldn't accuse Melanie of doctor excuse
me dr. Melanie of having one where you
credential dr. Mel but she is giving you
ways to figure it out yeah we she ate I
can tell you some other ways I hope
stick your finger in there no does she
wear patchouli
that's I'd rather your pussy smell like
a fucking sewer in New Orleans
the day after Mardi Gras then smelled
patchouli oil yeah well that's why they
put it on their masks other smells
patchouli I'm convinced that that's the
smell of dirty box ransom I think that's
made from dirty vagina disgusting if she
says no no okay
stinky if she says where's she doing yes
she does it then you can try smelling
already cuz you know yeah the booty
cheeks opening is like I can't twerk
right I'd say another way you can tell
is everybody at Burning Man how's it
stinky pussy everybody yeah they're not
showering for a week and there on that
playa and it's hot and all they do is
hose people down there's no showers
white girls with dress yeah if you have
dreadlocks it stinks down there too yeah
yeah definitely and if you're white if
you're white and your dreadlocks
definitely I'm gonna go and say a lot of
leather a lot of leather wristbands and
yeah your box stinks and well leather
pants aren't very porous either I'm
gonna go with leather pants I I'm gonna
go and this is a this is going to be a
hot debate yeah women in Birkenstocks
yeah yeah you could tell by a shoe wear
Footwear yeah yeah you look down if they
like dirty feet no I don't know if the
Birkenstocks really equal that but I do
think how you take care of your the rest
of your body is indicative of how you
take care of that yeah I think it's true
sick and I think
that if you guys are comfortable enough
and you already go to a house go smelt
identi dirty dirty underwear I know it
sounds kind of gross but I am telling
you that you should take a chance and go
smell it what do you think
is she the vagina detective yeah you
think I mean I guess you could tell
right by smelling her underwear I mean
if we're gonna go through the trouble of
having her twerk and then finding her
dirty undies and sniffing him why not
just hook up with her and find out just
eat that stinker all right you could put
a digit down there and sniff your digit
I mean isn't that I don't know I what's
the woody what have you been doing
historically yeah I mean I don't care
yeah why why I work together fucking
trash can okay
I've genius I remember encountering one
that was that in where'd County no I
countered one Oh not like the most
pristine and whatever didn't bother me
okay I mean I wasn't eating fucking
meals down there you know
all right yeah you just shove it in I
don't know I think all this stuff about
stinky this in there it's like you know
what world people are though it's just
some days you nasty Sunday's you ain't
I've smelled my own balls like Jesus man
that smells horrific right I mean don't
you feel like there it's just hot and
some there's good days and bad days yeah
bad boys sure that that area between the
your thigh and the ball you can put your
thumb down there like this yeah that's
nasty not on every day but there's some
days where you're like that is foul yeah
I think it's interesting that there's so
much focus on stinky vaginas but stinky
balls are another problems a real issue
it's another thing that's dividing our
nation there's cat people there's dog
people
stinky vagina isn't stinky balls no
one's talking about those stinky balls
no it's like so one
problem that's silly silly a real issue
yeah yeah I mean like it's just all it's
all body parts who cares right let's see
her other her other insight let's check
out dr. Mel sure if a girl is always
crossing your legs you know she has this
think you busy because why are is ice
crust it's not comfortable I'm not
talking about oh it's ladylike la la
it's not comfortable to have your legs
class at all time so even I'm not a lady
or telling the truth nobody wants to
press down is that all the time only the
one with smelly pussy yeah I do love her
accent and I could watch her all day
yeah I just
I like watching expression yeah she's
really pretty nice Bahamian no you're
just super humus yeah why I hate my
Bahamas it's not that accent are like
she's an island bahamas like something I
don't know okay but you said it like I
know the island I know wait aren't you
the master of accent yeah you tell me
master I thought she struggled just
enough where it would imply that maybe
English is a second life
okay that's what I thought yeah who
knows you know alright is a patois
sounds like certain puts what could be
crazy but then they have like they're
sweating from the pussy what do you
expect of course the pussy smells like
why are you sweating I mean I understand
its skin and stuff but you know you
sweat most people stink so if you start
from the pussy your birthday your pussy
probably sting - yeah good there is this
is an interesting theory
she also says you could do this I know
this is like pretty aggressive move yes
it's a you in the car and you're driving
or like still going I'm good like 20-30
minutes you guys get to your destination
she gets out just act like close the
door for like five minutes you come back
out and be like oh I forgot something in
the car go to the car and smell the seat
of the car if the car smell is and they
are different that what you used to you
know that's her and you know that's most
likely a vagina hmm
dr. Bell so interesting she has more
suggestions more there's more than this
yeah
when she's really obsessed with these
stinky vaginas something someone got in
her head somebody said it to her once
you know yeah but then again there is
the regular mode if you want to take
your chance or whatever well while you
mess around I know you all do that
already so I don't need to tell you but
you finger her and then say anyway some
people don't run away they still take
the air and be like okay I was thinking
but I was too deep in it I think she's a
native French dude yeah maybe or Ivory
Coast or something could be I don't know
yeah I don't think you know I don't know
I'm throwing it out there Turks and
Caicos yeah I'm saying maybe like
Haitian could be they do that'd be a
good guy I hear I hear more than patois
than an actual like ESL thing happening
okay maybe even Jamaican no okay I'm
gonna go with Haitian because she's like
light-skinned and she's got the blue
eyes imply Haitian or Bahamian where's
it okay I know where's Bruce rihana from
Barbados she's from Barbados she looks
like she's got Rihanna's coloring and
stuff that's not your just stop guessing
never guess again that should be the
name of your new album never yes never
talk yeah stop talking this is kind of
exciting one of the things that we play
on here quite often is you know when
when great audio comes into our life
yeah let me see if I can this is this
was such a big hit on her show and we
assumed it was gone that it would never
enter our life oh wait are we doing it
doing it I'm so excited it so just tell
us how it happened your phone is off oh
my god no no my phone my phone was
silence and I don't I don't usually
accept phone calls after a certain time
we put our son down and it's time for me
to relax I never I normally don't even
look at the phone and I got a voicemail
from a strange number I didn't recognize
I transcribe I like to look and I hit
play and this is what I heard anyways it
said why does it happen okay did you
know yet what ruin and let me know I
hang coaches if he'd been does evil
equal radish
you know that's my cubicle
call me so for those that don't know
we're over a year this woman has been
leaving messages for Salome on his
Persian woman has been leaving message
for Salome on Christina's phone that
because she got a new number about a
year and change ago yeah and there's
always aggressive cursing Farsi in some
broken English yeah every time people
right in our Farsi speaking listeners
translate for us yeah but she had been
gone for so long we assumed months I
mean I I know the last time I know it
last we heard that there were squirrels
in the trees and she's putting plastic
bags in the trees to get rid of the
squirrel and it worked and that was I
think when we moved here so that was all
I wanted to know what that Farsi ladies
[Music]
amazing pause and these messages that
Christina keeps getting non-stop on her
phone to me are that the person who's
leaving them never hears back from
whoever she's contact whoever you're
contacting hates you like how about you
just stop you guys aren't friends
there's sue there's no love there
[Music]
number then you texted
that's our man
okay that's brian days such a good son
and i thought we'd never hear from the
salome thing again now if you hear I
don't I don't speak Farsi but she does
say in English I lost my phone yeah now
that could be a key component here and
why we haven't heard from her in so long
could be but I'm glad she's back has
your number saved
she wrote that one day she has it in her
old contact book that they read put into
her new iPhone yeah
so anyone speaking Farsi if he could
translate that one let us know what's up
with her and if she says her name who
are you she never says her name I don't
know what to call her
but I brought so much joy back into my
heart knowing that the salami lady is
back in town it's a lot I was actually
just thinking about her a week prior
like I wish I'd get another voicemail
from salome lady it's been so long I
know I just thought we figured it was
gone yeah I mean you had every we had a
good reason to believe it was gone yeah
it's been it's been since we moved here
in November and she was leaving messages
to cover your lament your citrus and in
plastic bags we had that one time yeah I
know because the squirrels were eating
the citrus and if you cover it in the
bags they don't they don't eat it yeah
so silly yeah yeah
so do you want to maybe is it time I
mean they can is it time do it let's hit
it
I want all the sound effects I want
chips on Bowl I want a cat eating kibble
and I want a brand-new sound effect for
this announcement okay this is a huge
announcement here we go we'll get
explosions okay
[Music]
sound effect one now that usually means
big announcement chips in a bowl that's
a cat eating kibble that's my episode
it's a cutest sound it's such a cute
sound that means even bigger even bigger
and yes now we go through the regular
big announcement
[Music]
and now to cap it off to make it even
the biggest of all announcements a new
sound effect so utensils clinking
against glass this must be major news
major news and it is Tom it is
he's share with you but last year you
know I came out as bisexual yeah and
this year I'm fried don't know falling
by but on a real note you guys remember
I taped my stand-up special in June and
meat rattle and I am proud to announce
I'm proud to announce that it will debut
on Netflix
that's right guys get it ready put it
put it on your list
October 10th cue it up cue it up
Christina P mother inferior is the name
of the special and you can search for it
starting this Friday and you can put it
in your queue and your list of stuff you
want to watch and it debuts on the 10th
of October and you can watch
long time coming Jean longtime listener
first-time caller
I'm very excited for its but it's been a
a road and I'm so I'm so excited for you
guys to see it and this was filmed in
front of mommies this was a mommy
exclusive and just so you know there's a
lot of shout outs but there are shout
outs in my special to your mom's house
listening so it's a tribute to the
mommies if you will it's really exciting
I'm so excited I can't wait couldn't be
happier for me I called it mother
inferior also as a shout out to the
mommies so it's super your mama's house
centric yes yeah
it's a really great hour I watched it
live yes you bring me up and that did
bring you your voice you'll hear it in
the opening of the special its pile of
money it I I left it in that you're my
Jean is bringing me up that's how
special that was October 10th you guys
get ready get ready get ready
I can't motherfuckin wait I can't wait
either it's so exciting so amazed are we
gonna watch it every night before we go
to bed together an hour rotation of my
stand-up special oh yeah well that's
what I do every night I watch mostly
stories completely normal
goodnight and then I kiss you goodnight
and I pet the dogs yeah I have a little
video of things I put on YouTube and I
watch all those designer of yourself
myself yeah how could you man I'm sure
there are people that do that there's
definite people that do that that's
crazy
hundred percent people that do that
speaking of patois yes there's this is a
real Jamaican guy and he's blown away
that an Asian man is in his store and
speaks bath wash it's pretty funny
oh it's all gone know what yeah and
Chinaman come pick up your money
well Chinaman submit upon some London
thing Amina and give me money what we
did have enough customers appear so
Chinaman comet Alabama rotted so but mom
ratted this in among a lot more Tanner
won hey you want the money me me Molly
didn't call me in Martin you want the
money time when I want the money young
learn too many know
yah mahn meanwhile all my money uh what
do you want yo you get that is weird
right yeah it's Charter and like faces
to put an accent on it you just go like
that doesn't add up
I mean I don't know about you but I'm
pretty open mind and I don't feel weird
do you feel weird like what do you what
do you think you normally should here
uh just different stuff I mean it's true
like when you see huh
whenever you see like gingers and
speaking Spanish I always am like oh
that's interesting
like you just don't assume than a ginger
because their red hair makes them yeah
not intelligent no no it's just like the
language isn't usually associated with
the way they look no I know I'm just
kidding is like an Irish person speaking
Chinese you're like wait yeah like
Canelo Alvarez the boxer is this this
redhead white guy and you know he's
Mexican so he speaks just Spanish his
English is terrible
yeah and when I would study abroad like
I remember there was you know there's
redheads and you're like you speak
Spanish and they're like yeah I was born
here and you're like oh yeah you guys
are everywhere
remember that time we saw that white guy
totally spit in Chinese that's the
that's thing I was crazy
that's the wildest of all when white
people are fluent in any Asian language
it's usually by the way blows Asian
people's minds like that's like when my
sister spoke Mandarin that dinner do you
remember that yes of course it does oh
yeah it's so it is well it's such a
foreign tongue like I think that's
what's so bizarre like I've never seen a
white person speak you know Hindi
have you no I mean it blew my mind of
course it exists but like you just don't
you don't assume yeah I remember being
in a museum
probably in Paris and there you know
they had the tour groups yeah and there
was a Japanese tour group led by a white
woman and she was stopping at every
painting with this Japanese group just
ripping through Japanese you know with
all the little mannerism Monet I'm Abby
they were all I know
that's sounding good so you come from me
yeah we come from we come from vietnam
vietnam vietnam born speaking patois
because lot me friend from patois and I
have house in Barbados I'm asking about
their money hmm
see that's how you do it man Barbados
Cecil Barbados they talk this way to
goes back dr. melody yeah yeah
assumptions love black girls yeah me not
mind me big buddy
he took he hesitated he had the nerve to
hesitate on that question just what
happened was he was honest in that
question and he said a lot he's like a
black girl like he's like I can tolerate
it yeah but you live in jail you
shouldn't love black girls I'm saying
stupid stupid ass but it's so stupid huh
go back to Saigon motherfucker hey Dan
Aang motherfuck shit shit you ain't shit
speaking of coming hard oh my god nobody
said that we didn't say that I'm talking
about wow you know we found no we found
no early footage oh yeah no early for
the show no no you want to see his early
footage no it's pretty cool please don't
such new kidney and gradually feel the
Jing in the kidney chain into Chi okay
and feel the kidney
have a connection down to the testicle
he has been OGG who's dead yeah
for 40 years living instructions well
what did I tell you my theory was is
that he's just a pervert he's been
talking about his balls since the 70s
it's evidenced here and he wants to talk
about his cock and balls all day and
make a living at it
now he does good for him I went lady
when you reverse through your nipple
connect to the back here it doesn't
connect the band after that from the
back make a lied out to the kidney it
doesn't start the kidney for why Mossad
must add the kid man when you finish the
kidney inside the testicle testicle is
incredible factory producing a lot of
sexual energy okay and the biggest waste
in a human is the decoration demo see
yeah he was a perv since then he's
always like play with your nuts yeah and
Jack your digging yeah and then you'll
be better yeah and especially if you're
not circumstances you gotta do this even
more that's true now that I hear him
speaking back then he should know he
should know circumcision by now
I know saying it's been 30 years he
should know circumstances yeah he's like
you're not you don't want you cannot you
don't know how to talk form neck massage
the testicles Christ looks like a monkey
yeah whew it feels I look like a
chanting inside you it's really
something content at home you know you
do at home sometimes can watch TV and do
that
yeah he's been a pervert his whole life
what did I tell you
supports my theory that he's been a jerk
his whole life doing the stuff
embarrassing himself and and making
audience is uncomfortable and now look
and hold that hold a ho testicle and
mossad Aloha the minnow so few be a the
Jim 10 into g-man Mossad 36 Tom Cheng
Han reverse the counter clockwise 36 so
he he upped it of course it if jerking
his dick that long
yeah he's built the tolerance no you a
neat pole yeah yeah he's been jerking
his dick forever man dude that's crazy
my Theory's right I knew it he's just
been a pervert since the beginning yeah
Rob Rob Rob see and then it turned into
that it started with just massage your
text testicle and now 50 50 50 he nasty
he's got he all you have to do is just
nut all day yeah it's so silly that's
all he wants to do nasty as hell he is
you think he's married who's mrs. rub
rub hmm I think he's been married yeah I
think he's done been married and then I
think he's been through a few she caught
him sharpening his knife a few many too
many times yeah she's like are you are
we ever gonna do it he's like wow
happening my nightmares shop yeah I
think he's been dropping that that load
everywhere do you think he's just really
he really is just into sharpening his
own oh for sure right yeah and sexual
energy and yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think he just wants it all the time
that's so gross would you kiss him no
what like a nice soft yes why babe stop
kissing would you would you make out
with him would you kiss his rub rubs I
don't think it'd be very nice would you
rather make sweet love to him a tease
rub rub or present-day rub rub
think about it and want you to think
about it because I think present day I
think president why he's just so much
more experienced but it's like musicians
were you're like I like the early stuff
because they're so raw no I like I like
him no I like him now you like the
technique refined he would know so much
he would just school me now back then
he'd be like fill your balls but how're
you do that yeah 36 times already do
that that's nothing new but no he'd be
like pull that circumstances back let me
do it really for you yeah you guys are
gross no I can't say what happened
yesterday you were laying in bed sick
and I went out to the front yard and I
found a dead rat you did now we've been
laying out rat traps to catch these
assholes that have been shitting in my
kitchen
we're telling you guys about it yeah I
mean look they can live outside that's
fine but then when you come into my
house you shit yeah on my floor
it's a problem it's a fuck you right
yeah you said we're in the same shit
yeah I got on you know what the key was
though we set out all these traps and
everything the guy that came over to our
house showed me that under under a sink
in the kitchen where the pipe comes in I
might have already said this but if I
didn't there's like where the pipe comes
in there's also a space type meets the
wall damn it and it's bigger than the
space needed for the pipe to fit through
the wall yeah so I got that insulation
foam yeah and sprayed it in there yeah
there's no wait we never saw them again
after that rat lock and and just so you
know rats the guy showed us because they
need opening this big and I'm holding up
my finger it's maybe the size of a dime
no no sorry nickel a nickel and as long
as her head can get through the hole he
said they can squish their shitty little
bodies into your house so when you think
about it they find an opening that big
not hard to do so these assholes come in
your house and they poop all over your
stuff it was so nasty so when I found
that rat yesterday so I was thrilled and
I put on some latex gloves and I double
bagged it you know but I was I was
at how happy I was to catch a dead rat I
was you were talking about it a lot I
took a photo I sent it to you I texted
it to the guy that helped us set the rat
traps outside and I kind of got worried
because I was like the only thing that
could have made me happier is if we set
up hidden cameras and I could watch it
die
listen to yourself I know I worry
because I was really thrilled because I
feel like he did us wrong who's the
psycho killer now that was me I know is
I'm a little worried how thrilled I was
to find it dead yeah you were well just
cause it's a threat to my my young yeah
a threat to my home to mcclellan us ever
how just it's so only people poop in our
house should be Segura's period yeah you
little jeans and me three people who
poop under this roof that's it and guess
guess their life and the nanny you know
they come over to the plumber took a lot
of leeway on that yeah
then he get electricians yeah gene gonna
take a dump in here I can't believe you
bribed his nasty morning down to our
house yeah what a jerk jerk I was like
nine - come on now you should take that
shit early anyway that happened and then
the other
last week we were having breakfast and
as we do and we have our coffee and then
we eat breakfast and you had to take a
dump in the middle of breakfast like you
felt the yeah the tug like you had to go
and what I think is interesting about
you is that when you feel the need to
shit you keep eating yeah you eat
through the pain of having to take a
shit depends depends on how good the
meal looks and how bad I have to shit if
it's a mediocre meal I'll be like I'll
just shit later but if it's like wow if
I go like this is gonna be an awesome
meal you know then I'll go shit now no
you mean if it's a wait if it's an
awesome meal you'll go shit now and then
come back and eat it cold no I'm saying
like if I walk into a place and I order
food and then they're like foods on the
way Oh like I have to take a shit and
I'm like this is gonna be an amazing
meal I'll go clear the chamber to really
enjoy the meal oh no I'm talking about
the food's already in front of you or
we're in the process of eating this
happened last week remember I gotta take
a shit yeah we were eating already how
urgently though there's so many levels
but for me for instance I know like hey
I have to go the need to go is kind of
not making this meal enjoyable so I'm
gonna get up go take a dump come back
eat my food cold but at least at least I
don't have to shit yeah I don't think
like that
Yesi walk me through your logic because
I I just don't think I don't get there
and then eat and feel like I saw it like
I could take a shit after shit those are
different could it happen yeah
right now right now but if I can I go
have to shit right now
so go just depends you know so your
timing it's just it's just the level of
severity yeah yeah yeah how severe and
again how good this meals gonna be if
it's like really enjoyable I'd rather
not have that feeling of having to share
yeah you know interesting yeah sweet
they wish you paused I think our guests
gonna be here any moment
press pause let's press pause well
that's cam wait he does yeah yeah it's a
great thing to bring up when he gets
here be back very soon and we're back
with big under the weather so we're here
I'm under the weather we're here with
you know you even know oh my god don't
even tell her so you know fighters have
nicknames yeah so it's like Iron Mike
Tyson yeah
do you know what his nickname is as a
fighter Brendan the jeans nope god this
is so exciting I cannot tell you how ok
are you ready yeah tell her your
nickname as a fighter
big brown oh yeah I think I saw somebody
write that yeah I got it from Brian it's
because he took it like that biggest
shit's in all of the years ever that's
me and Cain Velasquez we have to battle
over that name so do you guys when
you're because there's all these stories
about
I don't know if you remember when when
Phelps Michael Phelps was training yeah
that he was eating like 12,000 calories
a day yeah did you have like heavy
intake when you're training or no did
you eat calorically a lot no not really
I've never been that like a huge eater
I'd say I'm more in tune with my diet
now that I retired that I'm in show
business then
yeah it's fighting really is again when
you're fighting you can kind of eat
whatever you want because you're gonna
burn it off that's what they say right
no but isn't that no I worked out
non-stop I wasn't like you know the
biggest thing for that if like you if
you follow football you think about like
those two days and then you're like wait
how are guys still fat you know because
like I'm serious like you would go you
you think about like how much you're
moving and burning in in like in like a
summer case five weeks that's only five
I go against that it's like normal shit
and also the guy stays so fat out of its
genetics that's that's a big part I
think it's eating eat so much yeah
that's the thing
cuz I used to do kung fu in the park
when I was 28 years old and I'd burn so
many calories but then I go eat a bean
and cheese burrito
yeah and two stalks and then I was still
fucking fat my mentality has always been
like I would do like an hour work out
with a trainer and then be like I guess
I could eat like 15,000 so I've never
been so self-conscious of my diet toll I
started doing comedy like but like
really you know whenever it comes to
when I'm backstage yeah I usually like
spread my legs so I'm not as tall
I'm usually super self-conscious or what
I wear because I don't want to look that
big oh I see that's interesting
do you feel you feel really think about
what you're wearing oh wow in the in
terms of what that that you don't want
to appear like too much of like a stud
yeah well you don't appear too big like
I'm not gonna go on there with like
Under Armour tight yeah
compressed shirt yeah that's not that's
super lame it's also like it's funny
with comedy if you have a physical
that is like a blessing you almost want
to disguise it yeah super muscular guys
shouldn't try to show the muscles super
attractive girls like I'm sure you dress
it down right can I tell you something I
have huge tits like huge tits
I would never guess that's right no and
I cover it there there there there you
know that and I cover him up I'm fuckin
like quadrupled above a quadruple date
ago I'm a thirty-two like F I'm not
exaggerating and nobody would know it
because I I hover and Phyllis Diller -
had huge tits did you know that anyway
big tits
yeah gold-seekers Tina do it stand up
thank you but I've had women in the past
tell me you should show them off and I'm
like no one's gonna listen to me that's
not funny it's distracting exactly it's
gonna take away from your actual talent
right and now yeah if you see like angry
long legs with heels and stuff you're
like oh people aren't listening what
you're saying they're looking at your
finger not gonna take you serious yeah
and they're gonna be like is your vagina
stinky yeah they might they might like
you know Welford and also when I first
started doing it I think Rogen's
wouldn't tell me that she's like you
don't want to show your tattoos it's
distracting really he's like yeah but if
I do so like I'm in San Francisco this
this week if I'm so that's my crap they
all know I have tattoos it's different
but if I'm at the Comedy Store Laugh
Factory or improv I cover my tattoos
that's interesting I think there's a
there's a lot to be said for that
I noticed for years now when I would
tour with Joe but you do big show it was
there even when he would shoot he would
wear like baggy long-sleeve shirt always
always never like showing that he's in
shape never showing the tattoos because
and you're like oh yeah he just looks
like a black shirt like you just don't
even you don't think you make about you
listen what he says exactly interesting
I've never heard it from a male
perspective because I've only ever heard
a dealt with it as a female in comedy
but I guess guys struggle - for sure I'm
already I don't mean it now I'm gonna be
into like I'm way too into fashion where
if you guys didn't know I was engaged
Mike oh he's gay it
yes I'm super into fashion Oh everybody
thinks you're gay yeah
it's pretty yeah that's a fair point but
I'm super into fashion
super into fashion where I'll pick out
my out like I'm outfit picked out for
Thursday night's show already I'm Miley
picked up for next Friday's show already
yeah and now you like it do you pick out
your own outfits or do you have a
stylist if you look and I'm liking uh no
like I I you have swag I hired a stylist
for one for like one time when I was
doing this thing on E
and like we talked back and forth on
it's like what you don't know what the
fuck'd like I know what's in like you're
so old school lady you know she what
works for Jared Leto isn't gonna work
for me we got one for you though if you
want if you want to try someone else oh
yeah for real yeah yeah there's all the
stars yeah yeah dude The Dude's tight
you like it like you hired them for your
[Laughter]
god yeah what are you wearing I was like
no no he gave me a bunch of shit about
it but sometimes it's good because let's
say they give you some crazy Gucci
jacket yeah can you do a special with
that or you do yeah with that yeah well
you got to give it back to him so he
price shouldn't pay for that cuz you
can't rock that thing again it's tough
to rock that again yeah I mean like you
she has she just shot a special and
before you got here well we just she
started in Seattle but we just announced
that it's airing on Netflix
he has a very fashionable Christian Dior
Dior dress it's work I had to hide these
tits because it's can't wear it again
well I can't wear it again but then
again I have it in my closet is like oh
that's my special is my first special
dress but it's tailored like you can't
like a wedding no it's your body it's
tailored perfectly I had to camouflage
I'd to mask my big tits and you know and
I mean you can't give it to her you give
it Isis underwear in school my quinny's
if you have a daughter which is pronouns
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm so glad you said that because I
think it's true that like while it's
open mind that as people are at the end
of the day you would be like I'm
open-minded this Shh I love everyone you
ever seen I am Cait on TLC yeah it's a
12 year old girl who's born a boy but
she's going through the whole bottom
surgery and she's in high school going
on blind date yet I looked at my ground
went and our son's name is talking about
Liggett tiger in ten years she went oh
fuck yes I went can you imagine and she
I was like you'd still love him out of
course nightmare but it would suck ELISA
at least like let's not act like it
wouldn't like you would we would all
love our children regardless but it's
not like that that going through that
would be fun it's painful just and just
as like a man if my son's like your dad
I'm chaos I'm a power bottom bro yeah
I'd like a little while to get used to
yeah like I can't spike oh cool man I'm
like damn there goes kind of normal life
yeah you would adapt to whatever became
normal
you know I'm still gonna love him but
it's gonna take like with Caitlyn Chen I
like his language with heat with you
though he's like I'm power behind was
fuck that's like a mean you take a
little bit like with the Caitlyn Jenner
thing like everyone's like you just
gotta accept I'm like I get that yeah
and I've known her or him as Bruce
Jenner that's right give me a fucking
way to sit on that's fine yeah what's
wrong with even having the reaction of
like whoa what like that even that
reaction is considered your hateful like
no dude for my entire life she's not
used to it yeah yeah isn't it why do you
know that like so you don't know his
story really but he was born a woman or
a woman clearly in the first female and
went into fighting professional fighting
after all that in the UFC and then now
he's not just a podcaster he started
with stand-up thing I know I have seen
at the Comedy Store on the same lineup
assembly and I'll say this I told Thomas
when I saw you guys run the lineup
because I we
we really haven't talked to Matt but and
I said insanely lineup and that night
there's a guy on there who doesn't tip
we do stand-up and he's doing horrible
and I'm again I'm super self-conscious
that stuff because you know there's some
gimmick acts out there so he was going
up there and just completely bombed and
you came back like what the fuck is
going on you're like I mean how the how
these guys get up like I'm so
self-conscious oh my god hopes you and
talk shit when I go out there that's not
every comic thing so every comic who
hears anyone say something in their head
thinks like oh shit well no one they're
gonna think about me everywhere and I'll
say this and this is why I'm a writer
died for Tom like I'll kill someone for
Tom because I did a set at the Laugh
Factory
it is a bunch compensate delay account
Tom everyone you know when you're first
getting started like it you know you
guys know how it is and I came up
different you my path to this has been
completely different a lot of people's
for god sakes sometimes I feel like
Charlie Sheen doing tiger blood like you
we have no idea you know I'm saying so I
was doing a set the Laugh Factory and
then you Tom Texan actors they came in
you can do this like dude you can do
this man and just that little bit of
encouragement just fuckin I mean see guy
rockin Nessie Tom takes the positive
route I do fear and hatred you know I
mean I'm like you yeah I go negative so
that I motivate you that way oh but we
don't see what the wrong - but how would
you motivate that not for you my man
never I would never discourage somebody
trying I discourage people who don't try
know that what I hate don't try actually
met Brendan it was at a fight he doesn't
even know this but probably but I met
him at a fight and I cheered against him
that's good so I was going to these
fights because I was I was I was touring
with Joe with Rogen's tickets yeah but I
was I was opening for him yeah I think
it was in Vancouver maybe oh I thought
Arlovski
no I think I thought you thought
matryona does Oh Mitch you're on yes yes
yes so drama but I don't know it's wrong
okay I don't know any I didn't I didn't
know anybody in the US you know I mean
like I know some of the big names but
yeah I mean I'm
you know I like football stuff so I'm
sitting there and and Kalin shows up
he's like my boys fighting in this I was
like who's your boy and so we're like
it's like the weigh-ins you know and I
can he's like he's coming up he's coming
up and then he goes and he's telling me
about like this is what this guy does
this was this guy he goes yeah my boy is
fighting this guy they used to play
college football so there I go you know
I'm like a big I go where who where he
goes up he says metrion I go Mitrione I
go play ball he goes I thought you said
LSU so I go LSU I go that's my dog I'm
like go Tigers do so so then at the
winds I go yo man like Ellis he was
gonna fuck you out and then at the
fights man it was amazing I was sitting
next to Kalyn you would have thought it
was Cowens seven-year-old son fine I
mean he was like nervous as shit he was
so nervous and like like I'm trying to
get your attention like every fucking
five I was like and I kept being like
you boys make it fuck dude he was like
he wasn't listening to anything I was
saying he was so and you won that fight
yeah man when you won the fight he
fuckin lost his mind
yeah dude he was he was like it was like
a father and son what's in what he could
be since he's that much older than you
hunter presenting my dad what's crazy
about that fight that was like kind of
one of the first steps and me
transitioning from speaking of Caitlyn
Jenner but me transitioning from kind of
that arena into entertainment through
podcasting because especially at the
time there's no Reebok deal I won't get
too much into that but you could wear
any sponsor you want so I could wear you
know your guys podcast shirt out I could
wear Reebok Nike whoever I want to and
so for that particular fight I wore our
podcast shirt a bikini Fight Club
podcast yeah and so I turned down money
from these companies to wear my own
pocket
big baller brand before big parlor brand
exactly the u.s. feels like you're an
idiot that's fine let me wear my
podcaster
smart guy it started to take that's
crazy very smart and podcasting has
exploded for you guys yeah it's been
good man which you know what's crazy you
know a lot of fighters are trying to
match it with comedians because they
think that's what makes the fighting the
kid but it's not chemistry yeah because
you have two best friends talking we
don't really even talk about sports talk
about life girls and yeah whatever
politics and current events but so you
see a lot of people trying top it which
is flattering but so we get some fighter
who is better than me and some comic
more famous than Kalin you'll hear do a
podcast be exist
success like those guys it just doesn't
work it's lightning in a bottle it's
chemistry which you can't yeah okay
totally meant true and then and then we
start doing live shows that's Colin's
idea and then I left that old man in the
dust and Here I am it's crazy
hey ask you something since I don't know
I mean okay and in UFC stuff do they
guys talk shit is it is it like boxing
for sure it'll delete up like the ramp
up like the main weather I remember
giving more so than boxing let's talk
about it do you plan your shit on the
the at least the weigh-in of that me and
Mitrione you guys were talking metal so
Matt and I were friends before the fight
yeah way before we on the Ultimate
Fighter together which is a reality show
we're on that together and we had a
trainer before that so me and Matt have
always been bonded one way or another
yeah so when they called us to fight I
got a text from my manager and I'm like
I'll fuck the only fight man I wanna
fight Matt and so I text him like hey
bro I just got an offer to fight you in
Toronto and math like what he goes oh I
just got that for two and I was like
well we can't turn it down she can't
turn down fights the bad look and I
thought I matched up well with Matt and
you know gotta eat so I texted him I
just said hey I'm gonna accept the fight
let's sell the shit out of this thing
let's just talk as much shit as we can
so there is that element most most time
there's not and so I say let's talk as
much shit as we can don't take anything
personal i'ma say some rude shit they
put got it have fun see you at the date
of the fight and I put cool man and so
he starts talking shit to me on social
media yeah and he's like you look like
you have down you and you you look like
Adam Sandler and a Down syndrome mom had
a kid
and I put I put and this is true I put
yeah well in a time he's going through a
divorce
I put yeah that's not what your wife was
saying when we we had that mean greet
together shoes I fucking me and then he
just took offense to that and when I was
like texting Mike out dear you and then
it got serious and then at the fights of
dead serious yeah yeah we're cool
cool yeah so I just did a commentating
job for his biggest fight of his life he
thought masks we're gonna against
phaidor and I was the commentator on it
and the psycho
he won 30 seconds so I saw him after and
we're good why he's not on my show it
doesn't as a very like I said very
casual - it wasn't a fade or like
undestructible at some point he just
older so it'd be like it'd be like Terry
Bradshaw playing for papers stealing was
ammo is the best of all time people were
like this guy's like yeah but then
testing kicks in competition gets better
he's a little old school you know I'm
saying good for matrix like you put Jim
Brown at running back like yeah wasn't
mean really good like your fucking grip
ago yeah yeah it's like that yeah I know
nothing bro I'm a woman you know I'm
just crunket here I'm super excited but
you know I'm a big seminal fan and our
quarterbacks out for the season Game one
and then you go tough opener fuck yeah
wise man and there was and they caught
some unlucky breaks and I mean a game
could have been a closer game but I go
tough tough game it's a tough game yeah
it's a tough game to open with but I
still go like man like if they if he be
if he was healthy coming out of that
game you know I should be fine oh
definitely a great ball making the
playoffs night with a backup in it's
gonna be go to state though like the the
backups gonna be a stud he's a he's six
five one eighty five and their old line
is suspect I mean that kids from France
why was getting hit like you would not
believe it's also Alabama this guy I
know but this guy weighs 185 about to
get crunk he's I mean we're gonna have
we're gonna be tied in throwing this
might be dealt with it's gonna be it's
gonna be rough man okay continue asking
Brennan my very important yeah yes okay
so theoretically these are your friends
that you're fighting with correct like
it's it's your it's like it's like
knowing a comic it's like me texting
I don't know Ari and being like hey dude
I want if I can beat your face in well
cuz then three months exists with roasts
right cuz you roast friends that's true
but it's not physical like I'm saying
like I've seen people like I saw Ralphie
make it his feelings and that's that's
happened I mean
Ralphie's was highly publicized but it's
also happened on ones that don't air
where you hear about somebody getting
real upset like yeah like sometimes
people are like the fuck and you're like
I've had comics oh you know how when you
play when you do like tag off where
there's no host we call it tech yeah
character acting so when they you have
to introduce the next time I've had
comics roast off I gotta me before I get
up there well yeah so what I mean the
thing about those roasts that's weird to
me is when it's not friends you don't
know the person I wouldn't mind being
roasted by friends for sure
I mean I'd sign up be funny yeah but
like when you when I understand almost I
think when some of the people get upset
at the roses because they're getting
roasted by people they don't know yeah
and that's why it's blossomed sup set at
a roast I agree but I think that's why
they get upset is because they end up
getting slammed by someone that I
couldn't fuck are you are you you
shouldn't get upset but you also should
have sign up for this because I don't
know you but I'm asking him to
physicality of it like how do you like
you theoretically you like the person
that you're gonna fire right so how do I
know it's not like I'm firing Brian cow
like like me and Matt we're friends but
we're friends through the business you
know sounds part of the game so would
you fight a friend like could you could
you even do it physically I mean now
definitely not when I was fighting is
almost you know even guys I didn't know
I had a problem hurting like how do I
every fight I've ever had I always went
to the back like yo bro you alright we
even if I lost like a man you good like
yeah get the fuck out I'm a guy
interesting what is it like I always
imagined to nice to be like a world
champ cuz you're kind of a gentle giant
it's way too nice to be what's the
anxiety like walking to the oh my god
the worst it is right though work
because I I wasn't in its a hero 5 did
you shit ally aria
vomit not to pee non-stop never never
diarrhea but always said I was like
gonna be so much cuz I drink fluids and
then for every five every fight so for
the last one was a little different
before I retired every fight I'd be in
the back going what the fuck am I doing
here what am i doing right I've look I
get it gone you've seen the movie
Gladiator when they're about to go out
and he's chained to that dune he looks
down he's pissing his pants yeah it's
just it felt so barbaric it is nuts now
how about this cuz I actually didn't
know this - I was reading about you
sometime I was reading something that
you were golden gloves yeah I was going
Gloves champion in Colorado
yeah but when did you start boxing so I
only started boxing to pursue the UFC to
get them and maybe that was it after it
was so I started doing like like messing
around boxing was in college and
training can huh I do it just stay in
shape for football right and then I was
like you know I'm not bad and then went
to the NFL had literally a cup of tea
with the Buffalo Bills they're like
we're all set on white guys and then
sent me back home and I was like what
the fuck am I gonna do and then enter
the jujitsu competition won that and
then you had no jujitsu training I had
like six months eight months of training
and I won that and then the guys train
with that time Shane Carwin who's UFC
heavyweight chair he goes hey next week
is going Glen Simon oh that's cool
boring as shit that's cool he's like I
signed you up for it I'm like what he's
like yeah you're in it man cuz I'm
sparring with him on and off and so he
said took - do you think I mean is it
one of those things where you took to it
naturally about some of it I just
outworked everyone to be honest yeah
like I just I wanted it more like
especially in like Golden Gloves where I
had like eight fights and I had I had
all eight stoppages nothing went to
decision so it's just like it's just
your your heart especially when you're
starting out like you to have a big
heart means so much Wow I also they have
a lot of other options so coming out
ways like that or fucking teaching mom's
cardio kickboxing yeah with my brother
my truck was getting repo'd I'm like
what the fuck am I gonna do when you you
graduated Colorado yeah and then do you
get like you
have NFL hopes at that point oh my god
is my dream yeah yeah so how does that
like what's the process like like
there's obviously like there's combine
people and the draft and then you're you
get an agent and you're like look I mean
now you get an agent like right we're in
between so we went to a ball every year
where I see every year I play in the big
12 championship so you playing a big
full championship and they get to ball
game right and between that ball game
use you're talking agents kind of have
an idea I had some coming my way they're
like yeah you may be late round draft
pick free agent we'll see so then you
watch the draft don't get picked up best
friend gets draft in a sec around a met
his draft party brokenhearted yeah and
then nothing happens in weeks later like
a buffalo
the the buffalo is gonna you know bring
in to what happens that when you get
that call I was at like static yeah
you're just like fucking flying right
flying but I knew isn't still a long
shot because everybody's like case
someone got hurt they need a body
basically yeah if you're super gifted
you might make the team so I remember
flying down there tell my family friends
like dude I know how this game goes a
chance of me making this team are not
fucking good don't get all crazy and
you're flying into Buffalo flying to
Buffalo and so I fly to Buffalo get off
the plane go through like this weird
little combine worked out and I'm there
for not that long a few days I injured
my hamstring but to me it was like it
broke my heart ride away right I'm a
sense of person but I realize how much
of a business it was yes because I get
there like 43 you over there my name is
Brendan Eich but you fuck over them
again okay and then it's just like it
was just such a business it broke my
heart is like you know your entire life
you want to get to Willy Wonka's
chocolate factory yeah you get in there
like God they treat these midgets and
shit
it's also crazy how like if you follow
just like the NFL news ticker you know
it'll be like big-name guys something
like released today and you know he's
released and it's like was this much he
was going to against the cap so he just
kind of the bringing a young guy and
somebody came up and then it really
becomes like like it was just such a
business you don't really think about
that when you're a kid you know like you
just think you're gonna get there and
it's to me all rainbows and Molly and to
me a good time yeah
was not the case that sounds like oh my
god and even towards senior year I'm
like I don't want do this for us my life
I don't play football the rest of my
life I got like my dream when I was kids
Beyonce nightlife like cuz obsessed with
Jim Carrey Adam Sandler yeah I was just
gifted I was just the big family you had
sex with retarded
I'm sailor yeah there you go according
to Matt mature oh yeah oh for me it just
it it was eye-opening and it was a good
experience and led me to where I'm at
now but yeah you've had it you've come
radar now do you remember in college you
played you said in these big 12 games
you were playing against any big-name
players today I'm a big name I mean I
played I played against shit man high
plane Oklahoma and Adrian Peterson who
won the Heisman against in Jason White
had the Heisman yeah beat us 50 to
nothing all my city ID I played against
Vince Young when they won the national
championship time you played I beat us
72 three Wow I was on kickoff return oh
it was horrible and I was going against
this freak you made to the NFL and I
mean how many fucking kickoffs is that
yeah and he every time don't touch me
white boy I'm like bro you guys are
growing a lot of points I have to touch
you like it's football I have to touch
you man don't touch me fucking white boy
like dude I'm just what you get see
that's the kind of shit I love that shit
talking on the field you know don't
touch me white boy do you talk when
you're fight when you were fighting MMA
stuff do you talk shit why you're
fighting a dude or versus don't touch me
white boy so usually in Miami it's all
they said to me wait you played Miami
you played at Miami at Miami that is the
epicenter of that I am Ian just hot as
fuck sonorous and I thinks sonorous mas
yeah it would cut this bonds like oh my
god I'm in for a long day just say you
played tight end so I tied it in
fullback kind of a fullback H back but I
was I was also on all the special teams
so oh my god freeze man freaks right
freak
from so do you remember is there like
when you think back against like that
Texas team and Oklahoma just like do you
ever have those hits where you're like
oh like this dude like I'll tell you in
high school I played against Heath Evans
oh yeah who played in the NFL for like
ten years sure and to this day I've
talked to friends of mine that were on
those teams we still remember what it
was like to hit or be hit on eve because
it was so different like he was such a
beast that like even if you hit him in
the backfield like your head shook and
you're like oh yes like Jesus yeah it's
like a freight train took off you know
it was like it was another level so I
don't know if like in those games but
you're playing against all studs but
like all some of those guys are even
crazier right I'm trying to think there
was like I did see I never because I was
on I was on offense but I remember
seeing Adrian Peterson he was a freshman
or sophomore and hand the ball off to
him and it was like Tecmo ball we just
keep hitting Ange just fucking slinging
guys yeah and I remember running oh my
god how such a how do people tackle him
yeah like what are we gonna do yeah they
skorts whatever fifty points in a row
and I was like I don't how is he not
done housing I can be the best in the
world and he was those are the longest
rides home right like after those game
well I think the heartbreaking thing is
right then if I saw Takeo Spikes has a
line back and yes literally traps from
here to here yeah as dark as this table
yeah and you're doing hitting drills you
need a shirt off and I'm just like oh we
don't even look like the same species
like what the hell the fucking money you
make the team and you're like a big dude
I just shit compared as far as end of
the UFC heavyweight or NFL player I'm
just I guess I've never seen a football
player except for AJ when he came over
to our house ad hoc yes he's a stud
there's two kiss but that's the key of
spikes look at his neck no you could
have muscle here freak
this is problems for you there's a
problem you should have been like go get
a job it's like this ain't for you yeah
what are you doing white boy I'm like
you have that's a great point I one
thing Christina and I are definitely
interested in we bring this up as often
as we can first questions yeah I even
wrote it down it's funny you and I are
in the same way we're just chemistry
nice speaking my language fuck these
black athletes I bet Takeo Spikes dick
looks a lot like his neck thick I
thought I'd say about the biggest one
I've ever seen
first of all I'd like to ask the very
important question whose balls were
smellier MMA fighters or football
players apropos our opening clip I would
say I'd say football because you had
this big stinky lineman who don't really
give a fuck about hygienic
you know hygiene now my friend Josh
Potter we always have this conversation
okay Josh - josh is a comic ok and he's
from Buffalo and he says which position
has the cleanest assholes in the NFL and
the dirtiest and cleanest to be Center
Oh see he know he disagrees he says that
like quarterbacks have like an a.1 like
oh for sure in corners just like diva
super clean assholes yeah and that
basically the argument comes down to a
line and D line and this is where we
we've often had a heated debate
sloppy-ass fat ass Oh lemon have to have
the dirtiest assholes he says it's D
lineman and part of his theory is that
the aggression the chasing if you wait
that guy we just saw the picture of
what's his position he's a linebacker
and so what what what is his man-bag
just case to case yeah yeah it's case I
mean busy a Mike as you will you know
wait what is that
see you weak side I mean you know dark
side are they riding a three-floor blitz
all the time there's a lot of variables
dropping back and so what's he doing so
but football humor football asshole
humor though see I think Center because
they know they know the lady I've seen
up Tom Brady putting that those hands
that those golden hands yeah underneath
you're wrong you would never disrespect
that Tom Brady son yeah he's probably
like that shit clean today yeah yeah may
I see another photograph of that
gentleman we were we were looking at or
I need to see the whole body and
relation so I can guess so the dick
detectives we like to guess what the
person's dick looks like we're talking
girth length balls I got one for you I
played with a kid and he was a stunt man
I fell to his name's Lawrence Vickers
once you guess his cock sighs okay hold
on hold on well let's look at
photographs first Jesus look at all is
this guy probably six one meat and
cheese what's he weigh 235 240 lines and
complete rock-solid not an ounce of fat
on them makes me look like Adele
shredder normally I would go short fat
coke can a lot of girth I'm gonna go
long and lean on the painter mmm this
guy and I'm gonna go I'm extra long
extra long and lean and then I'm gonna
go high and tight on the ball there's
two big-ass dicks for you right the best
of all time bye she was the best who are
basically like we're about to run a
train all three tired yeah enormous
painters these guys your prediction is
that they're long and lean long and lean
huh long and lean I've seen a lot of
lean black dicks usually stack like a
vein yeah yeah
thick he's big old thick dicks right
yeah like that like again I had a guy
shouldn't Locker with what his Locker
was next time he's the captain our team
his dick was so big his name's Lawrence
Vickers you looking up Zeke was so big
he could grab it and talk into it like a
Mike you're sorry God you joke around
like a how you doing they literally grab
it like a mic
fantastic I've ever slices Laurie from
the fifth Ward in Texas and where's
Lawrence Victor not every day for
Cleveland Browns for a grip was a
captain of our team the biggest dick
I've ever seen but not a rack you're
saying just flaccid normal this guy
she's right from Houston Texas play for
the Cowboys
what do you play running back with you
he's like an H back he's running back
fullback freak man
she's a great leader fantastic of
adversity shout-out to Lawrence Vickers
you're a huge black dick whatever his
balls like not bad either is this him
here Thunder that's amazing yeah who's
got the bigger dogs though the MMA
fighters are they the football players
tell you what Rashad Evans packing heat
really yeah how about this pig eyes
Google to chaos spike for some reason
this picture of a Broderick Bunkley came
up I bet he's got a fucking piece he's
looking at you like you must see a big
dick look at that guy dude that's his
weight 306 now yeah that's his way and
he came in with like seven percent body
fat yeah freak yeah yeah you know I got
a small dick can be that freaky man it's
just not the way it works well see Tom
that's not true time in the past you
said that it sometimes it's it's you
know irrespective of well I heard that
she was just like oh some short guys
have some big old dick yeah I've seen
yeah Kalin has one of these sticks I've
ever seen are you serious yeah count as
a fat dick Rogen as a fat dick too
really I only hang out guys fat dicks
like you gotyou you checked them out
there no yeah we seen with my own eyes
whatever just like yeah you know hanging
around first time I met County we were
taking a piss next each other I looked
over just see what he's working with
yeah she's talking so much shit yeah I
just had to see for myself it's like
seeing a white Walker you know I'm
saying yeah like I had to see it for
myself and you're like oh you're not
lying man cuz I didn't know if I could
trust him in but he's thick thick and
long and long yeah surprise for combien
50 thick and long balls are long okay
grandfather balls and Joe I just saw you
know fat dick yeah you didn't see the
boss
[Music]
Lauren Snickers and Takeo Spikes you're
welcome here anytime
Brendan I'm glad you're here today
because this is the start of a brand new
debate on your mom's house very hot
topic Tom and I were eating breakfast
and in the middle of the meal he says I
have to take a shit
but then he finishes eating and then
shuts after now me on the other hand if
I'm eating and I have to shit I get up I
leave I take a shit I come back and I
just eat my food cold where are you on
this side of the debate well I'm with
this I keep it I keep it sexy if I take
your shit I just telling you when I just
kind of disappear and then come back but
would you eat your entire meal would you
finish your meal or would you get
alright nod get up yeah don't be
uncomfortable that's what I'm Spencer
I'm at though FM I at home am i eating
with my girl home I'm a nice restaurant
you're not in front of her no keep it
sexy man you gotta keep it sexy how long
have you been together five years that's
why she does the same oh yeah
can we have well did you see her give
that up in here what did you see her
give Bernie section oh is it meat you
didn't see not and I tried to stay away
from but there's like a little corner I
could see through his rough surgery
she's Mexican yeah Mexican is five come
on you know when you're Mexican you know
Mexicans survive do what they gotta do
man I'm saying you know that's why we
Mexicans this is kids that we do with
Mexico bro bro oh wow this is working
dog in a fucking regular just outside so
Joey deer could be my son I know I might
be my son in the 20 years he makes this
video what's up what's up man talk about
power
shit my dear oh my god yeah that's him
man bummer fucking video to show you how
I'm doing is there anything you don't
want your kid to be like is there
something you're just so adamant on you
don't want to be I can't think I know
you know what I feel like it is whatever
it is that you're like oh god whenever
you have that thought of like just so
irritated by something might sometimes
my mind goes that's what's gonna happen
yeah and it's not to say like we're
gonna be like it's like when someone
like when it irritates you when
someone's being indecisive
what are you gonna do in my mind we'll
go that's what that's what I'm gonna get
as payback or if they're super negative
yeah that's right and ah so you can't
help with a super like manic-depressive
or something that'd be a bummer that's
about I just live in your basement play
video that I don't want my kid to go to
a shot I don't want him to go in the
military only because I don't want my
baby to die in a war like that's yeah
just don't want that's fair that's fair
but what about entertainment
it's a terrible but if he if you hurt
and hurt his parents it's a prophec it
might be like it's it's gonna go like
extreme one way or the other ac they're
gonna be like I def we want to do it you
guys want to do like what you guys think
yeah I hope it's the opposite me too I
mean stand up I definitely hope he
doesn't you know
really yeah man it's not a career path
but I would recommend to most people you
know it's a lot of suffering it's a lot
of like the grind is real it's real man
like you actually got to come in at a
point where like you have success in
other aspects of your life to kind of
hold you up as you do it but like if you
were 23 I can't imagine I came here late
I can really do it as far as relation
works yeah because I am debate with one
comic they're like well while you're out
playing grab-ass I was on the grab and
well it's complexion face yes it's a
little different but I'm saying like but
also like I mean I know you could this
this is kind of being negative but like
the probability of things even just like
remotely work oh my god
neither favor I mean you have a better
chance of graduating Harvard Law than
getting a welcome to get into Harvard
I can sit my son down and go look do
this this an issue in Harvard yeah if my
son goes hey I wanna be the next Tom
Segura I go well I guess try and do this
it might lead you here and then you got
to do this and hopefully this works out
and they got it there's no more you got
to eat more like there's no there's no
hurting harder there's no blueprint no
that's true and that's one of the
hardest things about showbiz he's like
you think like I should follow this
person's path and you're like God it's
not everyone's path is completely
different yeah completely different and
they got stay relevant exactly are you
enjoying like you know the what I mean
obviously like you're having success
it's kind of wild but like are you
enjoying you know figuring it out best
time of my life really
yeah yeah it's been a complete blessing
which is religious but it's been crazy
man I've always wanted to do this and I
think just figuring things out and
making it work and being on the road and
showbusiness been it's been amazing man
like I just had a meeting last week
about you know TV show for something
I've always wanted to do like what I
should I got like a meeting that like me
shouldn't be taking these meetings
scripted show uh no like a host show ah
it's for because I do my podcast big
round breakdown yeah like that for TV
that's awesome hey so that'd be great
yeah great but just stuff like that your
dreams are coming true dude yeah or like
you like for me like when I because I
live in San Marcos when I Drive down
sunset to do a set the Connie store it's
like that's been a I get so excited man
I get so so excited and like my biggest
thing that I missed from sports was not
the fighting not playing the football
games but like the camaraderie like with
the guy like bone out when I go to the
Comi store mom in the back it's you Bert
Chris D'Elia Brogan Brian like it's like
fuck
here's Imran my guys man is true and
like I feel safe yeah that's the nice
part that is like the punter on the
football team but I feel safe yeah you
know I'm saying I'm like the punter yeah
like I'm not exactly part of the team
like I'm the weird punter but I feel
safe but you know with a few times
yeah any more years will be a long
snapper with field oh my god gene yeah
do you yes gene I have this guy Oh vocal
fry you know about vocal fry I don't I
kind of have it right now because I'm
sick
well we talk too much no it's like when
people elongate their that's why I talk
like a car - yeah yeah so it's like
we're always like ah and I like kind of
obsessed with that what is the educate
you on mindfulness meditation and malas
meditation see the interesting thing
about vocal fry' that we did a lot of
research and and we've been learning
about it's is that that's completely
deliberate she knows exactly what she's
doing that's an effect on purpose like
even if she's almost an act yes it's a
front it's like yeah you're such a white
kid who talked to black yeah making your
voice - but it's a thing for upper-class
girls to sound more intelligent like the
Nicole that sounds intense and exclusive
I think maybe they may be not
intelligent I think they just cool they
think they they say it more exclusive
like I'm like yeah house what you talked
well I'm saying like I think that
they're thinking like oh this is how Kim
talks exactly like this house is if
you're super hot and you really like
socks with like on the first day and
it's also like a lot of up speak a lot
of them do this too like it makes them
sound smarter but why smarter I think it
makes oh I think it's supposed to be
like a yes I think it's like a cool name
to do that's why it's like
it's like the the kind of cliched thing
to do right now yeah it'll phase out it
off I hope so yeah first thing that you
want to do when you're starting a
meditation wolf is get a good
comfortable seat I'm comfortable sitting
up on a cushion oh my god hers is out
one foot is in front of the other in my
vagina crossed line up in front of each
other well yeah
you can't have that and what some guys
no guys just do talk yes I know there's
actually a fighter fighter who talks
like he was a world class boy - oh this
is one of the worst cases we've ever
seen yes yes I only have audio of him
but I can put note no guy recently
though like there's no guy in this game
talking like this yeah listen to this
guy yeah Megan and I have been together
for nearly three years she's a beautiful
girl
I'm very much in love with and I have a
lot in common with what's that show
called polyamory oh I watched that show
Maryann's Oh Showtime yeah yeah yeah it
was all right the second 13-year old
lame bangs class yeah it was great and I
liked all and you know those dirty
hippies that all live together
they're so nasty it was so interesting
that I said oh yes I remember that guy
see he had a gym and his girl was hot
yeah dope show is all fun and games
someone to fuck a girl there was that
show and then did Showtime at gigolos
too right yes we were huge fuck some
fellow Judy check this out I saw homeboy
cuz I just live in BAM you know
I saw her no I make falls me on Twitter
but the bald guy though he's like
actually you know I consider myself a
feminist
yeah use the first one the bald one I
wait for which he went down on every
girl regard
yeah so I solve in with like a girl
pushing a stroller by Starbucks and you
would have thought I saw fucking OJ
Simpson oh shit my girls like my girl
watch - she goes why I went ice then I
go bro give it up and he's like oh my
god give it up brother and he's like
okay man it goes like that and just
scurries off Wow Wow I don't ask anyone
for any pictures I already had that
picture yeah he was with a girl with a
stroller
yes Wow interesting and I'm like maybe
his mom I think maybe keeps it on the DL
Sam I was like yo Finn you're gonna dick
somebody down you know like on the beer
and it was like too much would you now
if you had to hook your lady up with
somebody like you're off at war and
you're like I gotta get you a prostitute
while you're gone
would it be VIN and I'm hiring the
cowboys and angels ya know I would hire
the dude who is shred and super into yo
yeah
angel no come on I know I'm going crazy
I'm up first every time and he's got the
long hair and he always flipped it
inside yeah yeah i'ma fuck was a dime
piece yeah I wouldn't hire Nick used to
line the ass for my girl VIN was just -
I don't know I didn't trust him I would
hide the old guy I like right brace has
been on our show rice was on the show
he's all the times he talks like that
multiplication yeah ash yeah cuz oh he's
great he's gonna be like let's get our
chakras alone threat yeah it's more like
a chicken like afterwards she'd be like
that was really special thank you thank
you now I'm gonna go back to Brennan cuz
he's an animal
yeah you're way to people but grace
might give you a girl a whole new world
yeah it's artificial fired up and they
got Nick too skinny weird
I love the rap battles yeah and then the
lab he was so bad on the show oh my god
did you how about when they did though
gross when they had to write jokes I can
do this I don't need to write and just
gets up there and you never seen it yeah
completely bomb is great and then the
guy who does I've been working on my
raps my raps
by the way we're huge fans of Nick's
videos to be seen his videos like on
YouTube his music though come on you got
to go down the rabbit hole never done
that why did they stop making it I feel
like they ran out of material they're
like six seven seasons yeah I stopped
there I think let's get a new crop of
young cats who just digging girls down I
don't know why not do an all-black one
oh yeah good job
wouldn't you be into that horse so I
bought some whores yeah mix it up all
girls I'd like that yeah girls aren't
trying to do it though I know the girls
over that's a bad look for no brace was
like every time like I was like what so
ever you old ass hoe and like he was
like just to be clear I'm not some
back-alley trick it's not like 40 bucks
yeah like sticking my dick and I go come
on man you know you're oh ho oh he's
like I am a high-end like they they
always like make it clean and escort
yeah nah bitch you're a whore you just
can paid a ton of money for you he's
actually very nice braces very sweet
he's from the Midwest and he's like he's
really sweet he does a vitamin
supplement line I know I love grace and
wants to get into like health and $0 $0
see slangin vitamins that's how his
movie ends
he's slang in vitamins and still dyeing
his hair which one I'm working a sweat
I'm breaking a sweat
Darwin that's Nick Hawks down who's born
to be bad
[Music]
from the film American justice I've seen
that it's not from the film
my spirit start shit my mind top wire
you can't blame me for it
you spark my fire I paid a lot more
[Music]
right breaking a sweat that one's my
favorite voices screaming breaking a
sweat
it's kind of killing me because the
other guys ain't doing shit I don't get
why Nick doesn't come and just dick
girls down after the show that's a good
idea actually DJing maybe it would be
better lane right yeah I just put your
iTunes podcast playlist on and just
trying to see it up there anymore me
just Google breaking up I just put it on
you know what I found what I put into a
break we were theorizing on that he's
super airbrush it's our show so maybe
she'll breaking this guy we're breaking
breaking a sweat
the name of this song all these a few
episodes back I remember the episode
number we could look it up I'm sweating
and we'll do can't really call us but
seven you sir let us know it's really
comment on YouTube on yeah I want you to
hear you gotta hear it bro yeah just
[Music]
it's just not sometimes now yeah he does
it although you know he raps poetry raps
poetry writes down dicks he's one of
those guys that like you can't figure
out life but no that is so accurate
we've been trying to analyze I don't
know like you ever tried I'll join the
swim team my bucket I'll do the swim
team of Joe Rogan Joe does everything
and then figures out how to do
everything well right and like if he's
like his retarded yes evil brother
yes younger brothers like turn I want to
try like I would do everything to but
like none of it it's just a complete
mess - man and I love watching messes I
know he just can't figure it out just
yeah you know if you're like hey you
know Knicks you UPS driver but yeah make
sense yeah yeah and then you get to wall
Mike what the fuck you don't work out
wall make a new gig bro gig man trying
to figure it out and that's you know
life coach yep he's doing confidence
coaching teaches you to be confident yes
that makes sense yes cuz you gotta be a
confident motherfucker to fail so many
times so many avenues just keep going
like maybe you can learn a lot from I
don't know how much he's charging per
class but I can tell you your boy signed
up for it it can't be a lot of signups
for that if you want to be better with
cooking talk to chef if you want to be
better with comments talk to me Nick
Hawk raining raging skypes and emails or
phone calls ranging from $25 100 what
about impersonal
whoa four hours at my rate fifteen fifty
Wow you don't wait you don't rise to the
top of the most
sought after profession star on a TV
show for six years perform your own
music in Las Vegas his biggest clubs or
become self-made by the age of 35 of
being anything less than confident I'm
still I wasn't always that way
can you please hear to the world much of
my life yeah Oh Brendan please take this
oh here's a book Nick Cox hundred kicks
in the ass a guide to getting comments
and reaching their full potential I mean
the guy's killing it he's trying to be
uh fuckin Tony Robbins I get it
you sure I figure life out like you were
saying yes he's figuring in a nose if
this doesn't work I don't know what
happened why did I look down on it -
what's going on here is she just
remember that was his photo they showed
the shoot I'll tell you if you should be
writing confidence books can't really
his dick is right there on his website
maybe it is that is confident that's
unprofessional yeah right
oh good job man I mean I don't I really
don't hate I don't recite ya I respect
the hustle I just hope he fight you know
I hope he hits that homerun he's hitting
a bunch of foul balls right now yeah
like if his life is a baseball game a
bunch of foul balls you know what he
just needs Jesus he's one of these
people and you might be right you think
so yeah yeah yeah needs the Lord that
could be your kid man whatever your boy
turned into a male Oh what are you proud
of him like a professional is just like
a player god I failed as a parent
yeah he's just goddamn getting paid to
fuck I'm in my own lane man yeah of a
self-help book coming out next month
gonna keep showing yours better fucking
Lawrence Vickers bitch you played with
what's your nightmare Brennan that your
child would become
[Music]
one of those trolls on the internet like
sometimes I get it on the internet and I
i won't block or anything LD mmm and I
because I'll go to their page and if
they're not private most roles are I
will go to this page and if he has kids
I'll just deal go listen man you have a
right to your opinion you're a dad you
have a fucking you really yeah I go you
have a kid certain ones I know you have
a kid man I go in 20 years do you wanna
be that guy that goes hey son I hate on
this guy's way more successful than me
check it out and if you are single this
is probably why man I'm doing a solid
here
do yourself a favor respond don't be a
loser some of them like fuck you and
some like god damn it you're right
really yeah you just block them yeah you
so I don't see it I think everyone loves
me like what life's great if someone
else yeah how my brother will log in for
you oh yeah here's that custom account
and you're like just block people that
yeah I'll know like when stuff came out
with you know Nick Diaz or when I was
doing the Showtime stuff some people
might not agree in my opinions and so
the try to you know troll so I'm just
like yo pay attention today and he'll
just go through all of it so I don't see
any of it that's smart that's great I'm
gonna have Tom do that when my Netflix
special drops no people love it what
special is this it's my first one what's
your first one
yeah damn Congrats thanks June damn in
Netflix
shit dog you garbanzo beans man I know I
can't believe nervous for it no because
I've been fucking doing it for so long
honestly I was not because I've been
doing it for a minute and I Holly been
doing it 14 years so long so I was like
I was so in the zone dude I was like
ready go yeah but it's still it's still
like I get it even though for a while
but still Netflix now I'm I'm more
nervous to sit down and edit it and get
that process I don't know it's a fucking
trip because you just I performed in
every shit box in the country and I've
like you know the best way to do you
know like to be like over ready to do it
I think that's why I wasn't so terrified
because I'm kind of I'm like overcooked
for it you know so I don't know but it's
what's on Netflix like if you shoot a
good special on Netflix a time out
game-changer like it maker breaks
careers like there's some guys wear
whatever they didn't put the best foot
forward and then you kind of fucked when
you go back on the road if it's a bad
specialist because now Netflix if I
watch Dave Chappelle which is the most
successful special of all time most
watch don't know if you guys know that
yeah you watch that and it goes you
might also like and I watched Tom and
yours in Psych what the fuck you know
I'm saying yeah it's not if you don't
put your best foot for these days
specials you guys know it's great
I agree like I I watch some people shit
I think a lot of times they're shot on
spec and so you don't know who it's
gonna end up you don't know where it's
gonna end up and I do think some people
are like whatever what do you mean
because like sometimes when you shoot
especially you don't necessarily have a
buyer lined up yeah solely just shoot it
on you know at the hopes of selling it
and so maybe some people are like
whatever it'll be like on this tiny
platform no one's gonna see it and you
know they don't really plan like they
don't make it that great you want to do
with a plan
oh yeah I had a plan shit I've been done
planning yeah I've been done you ready
man all right you ready next couple
weeks over and out of just killing it I
know I love Tiffany she's
I've never met her she does oh she's the
best very very very talented yeah yeah
she's got like some new movie deals dude
she's killing it killing it just
fantastic I hope everything works out
obviously in your life and your marriage
but if it doesn't maybe anyway I'm back
with another upload today and by the
title of this video you may have worked
out that I am gonna be doing the guide
to getting a girl the guide to getting a
girl the guide to getting a girl the guy
to get together yeah oh god man you know
I mean such a struggle do you feel like
he gets lame uh yeah this guy about in
your in your single days and you're
riding a bus there's like a whole group
ii like world talking about caged rats
okay dread okay they're just there for
you guys I assume for you guys uh your
fight when you're act you're in the UFC
and you're fighting mm-hmm I mean
everybody knows about NBA and NFL and
like you know getting off the team
playing and all that stuff but like who
solo yeah here's but here's the
difference so NBA NFL they have NBA NFL
money so they getting different type of
hose right however if shit breaks down
we can beat up any NFL NBA player so
there's that kind of tribal yeah where
girls go holy shit there's one alpha
male right if a fighter walks in a party
you know Matt even at the ESPYs if
fighter watching them party everyone's
like okay there's the Alpha it's just a
fanatically like right and you're not
YouTube girls are doing a little drawn
to that however now I would say I get
more I hit on way more and more people
slam items now more so than ever that
I've gotten into comedy
not even close what not even close maybe
you're now a bit maybe it's because that
might be it but also may yeah maybe or
maybe also you know one thing people
like to do I know I comment you know the
common thing is that laughs they know no
I'll tell you why Brendon
if you look at the pool of dudes doing
stand
you're the looker of the bunch there you
go sorry
take-take-take you're the looker hey man
I've been doing this shit for 14 years
I've been looking at the dudes in the
biz aside from my husband who's a
handsome fella who I married the dime
piece there's not a lot of eye candy by
way of male comics you're funny and
handsome crystal is that whoa hey
crystal he's a little weird but he's a
diamond yeah Chris you know you have a
long neck but he's a little diamond got
a kind of nice long neck a lot of nice
long features on Chris long lean
handsome young man hilarious yeah nice
you've seen that dog I've smelled it
really yeah I would say Chris the most
handsome dude in comedy he's definitely
I mean I I would say that there's a well
we're gonna go tom
just you know I would say over the years
there's been a couple women and agree
with you on Chris yeah I guess because
there's some we are in a business of of
not good-looking guys no talking about
dogs the dog pound it's a male comics
with dog pounds I mean this it's the
place to succeed for like your the the
uglier and the the worse your attributes
that's better yeah who was it Eric
Griffin you know yeah at the improv and
he got after me and he was like I don't
know what the fuck that is comics don't
look like that look like this yeah yeah
yeah but I mean yeah I mean colleagues
look like you know like shit man like
bird like like but you know what's good
no no but I think the tide has turned
out because it's cool to work out and
that's if you look at everything Dave
Chappelle who got clearly on TRT
oh I mean what's TRT the sauce drone
replacement yeah because but you don't
go from his he was like fuck like 40 he
was so skinny so skinny and I liked
items that's where I came from and then
now he's like ya know and dr. Dre got
big
like yes that ain't normal is they just
get put on 30 pounds of muscle yeah but
now it's cool to be in shape that's true
it's I think it's different just respect
health more yeah you know it's like
weird like what much more so than 20 30
years ago that makes sense you know
people are always like I feel like
carrot top was the first Oh Carrie Table
two same so much he takes enough where
you might be able to you might be able
to convince him he could beat you in a
fight you know the chance yeah I'm like
do you got this Jim he's crazy he would
problems you would have to tape the
mouth shut if he will bite the fuck
every man for sure I mean they tape
their mouths shut
nobody rat top you have to he looks
dirty I'm so surprised you have your
teeth like that's great do you have all
of them are they are original yeah
they're all mine I'd like bevan ears but
okay oh my god these are veneers I have
perfect he's terrible we can't even see
let me say this person never no braces
no retired crazy rush once a day once a
day once a week
what do you not hist either pretty
fucking pretty nice you drink coffee -
yeah those are legit teeth do you floss
Oh
oh my god you're supposed to you gotta
start flossing it's gonna change your
whole game I'm telling you let's do how
we got Invisalign at 50 yeah that's good
he looks great though caramel it's great
yeah
time for the official dental update we
have the news you have stay off the do
it me anyway when you have veneers
deceptive do all the regular dental
protocols here's the thing
wait wait what just to be to get clear
for our audience here Brendon how would
you grade his teeth looking at them they
look nice right those are very clean
they're very straight
they're very white your gums look very
healthy and not red and bleedy thank you
um I think he's doing great so
genetically are we looking at like your
teeth or do you have a lot of dental
work done or no zero this about seven
years boy cuz seven years ago let me see
smile look decay Peter peep it I went to
dentist seven years ago the dentist fuck
that one goes oh my god
ones s time saw dentists I went bright
ten years ago bitch she goes yo you have
genetically gifted teeth you some of the
best I've ever seen
I went cool see you never and your gums
are good haunted and you never floss
ever never I drink the party and so
every night what pulled pork no problem
I think coffee like a motherfucker this
is my six cup of coffee today my shits
still kind of white kind of like corn
nuts we do the whitening never never you
know why my buddy did it teeth like got
super sensitive we do it too much yes
he's on a jet ski do booth knocked out
all his teeth knock them all in half how
awful was he doing it a lot that's why
you can't you good every three years
maybe you can do it professionally but
don't do those fucking strips man that's
dangerous you can feel and burning of
course yeah no I did I just did my teeth
whitening about six weeks ago and it was
might the what's that at Hoyts actually
the funny thing was 24 maybe 30 hours
later it was more sensitive than
immediately leaving but you can't drink
coffee right
I didn't say no for a day I can't do
that I'm out I tried wean off God for a
day I swear to God no cold sweats in the
fetal position on the ground SWAT how
much you drinking a day six Amina are
you hydrating enough yeah water colors
your pee up clear yeah so you really
balance out your call yeah I drink
fluids non-stop your teeth look great
Thanks you don't want the nearest thing
you want to do you should talk about
yeah what about the that water pick you
ever think about using that or anything
I don't feel like there's any me too
well yeah you said you're like
genetically guess yeah so what she told
me that is the same I'll have great
teeth mom pops my mom's little yellow
not gonna lie
yeah my mom's tea through your mom's
what my mom's teeth look like corn nuts
yeah that's straight my brother had
braces for about eight years now
computer guy computer engineer smart I
would suggest for this I mean look
ventually you're gonna how old are you
know 34 you gotta start flossing just
for your health for your son try it you
just said try it once you start it's
very hard to to not do it it does feel
good once I start doing it feels so much
better what if I get veneers stuff to
fly okay so let's yes yes yes yes yes it
doesn't it doesn't exempt you from
hygiene is there like a like a basically
like put a windshield on your car it's
terrible no it's painful and it takes a
long time I'm not gonna lie they shaved
down your real teeth they then they
cover it with the fake teeth the veneer
it's it's a very ordeal it's an ordeal
okay don't do it unless you hide because
I knocked out half a one wasn't kid
impossible yes no I was on the ring so
it was the oh so you've had been theirs
for a great like my whole life I've had
to get fake teeth because I knocked out
half of this one as a kid it's like a
playground accident nothing really I'm
not that tough guys we got an email you
work for them it's so much work so they
could grant a tooth too right yeah it's
a lot of money but at your teeth yeah
you spend the money here you go you guys
are all about teeth this is your team
you're out of here man
detectives police out here bro yellow
teeth you out Oh your mommy's I love the
palm cast and have a quick question for
you to ponder upon since every other
body fluid has a definite smell do
boogers and snot have a scent as well
yes have we become so accustomed to the
scent that our brain just ignores it
yes mommy jeans horrible sneeze made me
wonder about this keep it high and tight
lose sleep and dad boners Dan yeah I
mean I think you ever take one out and
then smell no is that disgusting no but
I know I smell like my kids breath when
he's got a cold yeah and you know that
that's the smell of snot yeah it's not
smell it's not smell yeah I think
there's definite smells everything
everything that's in your nose is not
gonna smell to you obviously because you
can get brain gets used to it yes so
that you can function yeah otherwise
you'd be just completely distracted by
that smell like like la if you leave la
for a while they come back smells funky
but to us this is normal I think okay I
don't like this whatever you're playing
[Music]
is that porno I don't know first
somebody said it to me that's Christina
sneeze on the show break your fucking
anything wait where can people see
Brendan just so they know I'm in and
thank you Justin that Brooke I'm in San
Francisco the same night here in Oakland
Oaktown Thursday yeah this Thursday I'm
in San Francisco
Cobb's I was like 20 tickets left he's
at kcon for tickets and then the
following Friday I'm at the Laugh
Factory in Long Beach oh that's great
t fat cake oh he's got very popular
podcast more than one he's got the
fighter the kid with very long and thick
dick bryan callen we learned we've had
on this show
yeah and then he also has a big brown
breakdown correct was that that's all
fight stuff I'm a citizen oh yeah I'll
fight boxing all right Baberaham what's
gonna happen wait isn't a triple G
Kanellis yeah what do you think gonna
happen I think it's gonna be a good
fight so give me the fight of the ages
like people think I think the big knock
for I mean that I've heard for him a lot
of people I've watched both those guys
fight a good number of times is that
people have knocked triple G's
competition they're like he's got
correct
hammerhand correct but it's like a bunch
of bums it's like you know I would say
bum Danny Jacobs is a tough customer and
you know some people thought he beat him
but and Danny Jacobs a bigger guy but
again I think you should be a really
good fight I think Canela wins in
decision but I think most the public
thinks triple G wins the fight then you
see them in a rematch and the rematch
would be the barn burner okay but it's a
great fight better fire right man I
can't last time we had this ghetto fight
it's been a long time yeah he really
does throws him both of them
world world-class route 49 and one or
some shit like that 42 and one once
whatever things like boxing that's a
good one
it's a good one to watch that's boxing
match match up all right it's Saturday
yeah don't forget check out bread shop
check out October 10th mark your
calendars mark your cue the mother
inferior on oh yeah nuts
I should also note that I'm going by
Christina P now so you don't have to
type in the whole fucking horrible last
name is Christina P just Christine pee
bro Oh mother
like pre today it's called mother
inferior and you can search for it this
Friday and queue it up on your list some
Soviet yeah he's very excited very
excited Holly move all right bye guys I
get back I'll shagird back
no flash a good man of course take in
your ass
[Music]
I'll show ya
no father shall get back
[Applause]
no father shared one thing
I forget that
[Music]
no fuss
your father said fuck by a horse cock
[Music]
no faster shake it shake it
no fuss
why should I get that no faster shagging
that love fire shagird bad man get
fucked by a horse clock
[Music]
but goes there yes
that sort of thing
[Music]
[Applause]